The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ok then, let's
start with problems.
And as we find concept issues,
we'll get to concept issues.
So, we talked about
shortest-path,
but we talked
about shortest-path
in a very odd way, right?
I'm a coder.
So for me I'm used to, all right
I go to one of these lectures,
I hear a problem, then
I get out of the lecture
with an algorithm and
the running time, right?
This time we got
out of the lecture
with no algorithm
and no running time.
So, what's the point?
The point is that we
learned some analysis tricks
that we can use for any
shortest-path algorithm.
And the advantage of knowing
that-- by the way too easy
to forget, at least until
you see the first real
algorithms-- if you
know that, if you
have to modify an algorithm, you
can still use the same analysis
to prove that your new
algorithm is going to be correct
and that it's going to be fast.
They're really
nice tools to have,
especially if you have to
do that on a problem set
or on an interview, or who
knows, maybe even on a quiz.
We'll see if that
happens or not.
We didn't talk about any
shortest-path algorithms.
So, we're not going to assume
Instead we're going to use
them as if we had them.
No, wait.
I don't like that.
That's kind of annoying.
Let's not do that.
Let's do something else.
We didn't talk about the
shortest-path algorithm
in lecture.
Let's build one right
now, how about that?
Let's turn to the graph.
Vertices and edges, right?
Let's see if I can
make this work.
Suppose we have a graph.
We have V vertices, E
edges and all the edges
have a weight
that's non-negative.
Sorry, let's make it positive
just to make things easy.
It's smaller than W,
so it's not too big.
And they're all integers.
Go.
There's brute-force, OK.
So, brute-force would mean what?
Enumerate all the paths?
OK.
Let's go over something
a little bit better.
Does anyone remember
the algorithm
that was taught in class?
The structure?
No.
Klaus mentioned Dijkstra
and mentioned Bellman-Ford.
Let's write them up here.
And they gave us
the running times,
which we'll try to
remember in a bit.
But, we don't know algorithms,
so no Dijkstra, no Bellman-Ford
for us.
What do we know?
Let's start with a simpler case.
What if there are
no weights here.
What if the graph
looked like this.
You're making my life hard.
Like this.
No costs.
All the edges have
the same costs.
What would we do to
solve the problem?
Say we want the shortest
path from A to E.
AUDIENCE: BFS.
PROFESSOR: BFS.
How's everyone
feeling about BFS?
What does BFS do,
really quickly?
How do you run BFS?
AUDIENCE: Take a starting
node and then you
can search all it's neighbors.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Pick a starting node.
Then, look at its neighbors?
AUDIENCE: And then you enter it
through each of its neighbors
to find its neighbors
and so forth.
PROFESSOR: Sounds an
awful lot like BFS.
What's the difference
between them?
AUDIENCE: Well, you go
through all of these neighbors
before you start going
through any of it.
I mean, you go through
all As neighbors
before you take
a neighbor and go
through all of its neighbors.
PROFESSOR: Ok, that's
the difference.
And it makes a huge
difference as we've
seen in topological
sorting last time.
So we have a list
and we're going
to use it to keep track of the
nodes that we need to visit.
We start with A. We numerate
all of As neighbors.
And the ones that
haven't been seen
get stuck at the
end of the list.
A, B, C. A is out of the list.
Then we take out the first node
from the list, B in this case.
We numerate all its neighbors,
A, C, D, E. Out of all these,
we take the neighbors
that we haven't seen
and we put them at
the end of the list.
take out C, we look
at its neighbors.
We've seen them.
We take out D, we
look at his neighbors.
We've seen them.
We take out E, we look
at all its neighbors.
We've seen them.
So this is BFS.
BFS has this concept of levels.
And another way to look at
levels is, if you start at A,
and you draw a
circus of radius one,
it's going to have all the nodes
that are distance 1 from 8.
Right?
Exactly one edge.
Then you draw a
circus of radius 2
and you get all the nodes that
you can reach in two edges.
And BFS calls these
circles levels.
A is at level 0.
This is level 1.
This is level 2.
If you look at this list and
you write down the levels,
you have 0, 1, 1, 2, 2.
If you had another
node out here, say F,
this would be
discovered when we get
to D. It would go all
the way here at the end,
and this is level 3.
In BFS the levels are
always increasing.
If you keep track
of parent pointers,
the parent pointer of
a node, at some level,
will always point to a
node at the previous level.
So, in BFS we get the shortest
paths in terms of edge count.
Make sense?
This is a recall, right?
It is not new stuff.
Everyone happy with it?
If it wouldn't have
costs, we could
use BFS to compute
shortest paths.
But, we have costs.
How do we deal with that?
Intuitively, I'd like to
make BFS go across this edge
faster than it would
go across the edge.
If I could do that, if this guy
could get stuck in the queue
before this guy,
I would be happy.
Intuitively, that's
what I'd like to do.
How do we do that?
AUDIENCE: Sort before adding?
PROFESSOR: Sort--
AUDIENCE: Sort your
neighbors sorts.
PROFESSOR: Sort?
OK.
AUDIENCE: What if you kept
track of it in a menu?
Kept track of your queue
as a priority queue.
PROFESSOR: Congratulations.
You deserve a Turing Award.
You have discovered Dijkstra.
OK, let's go for
something simpler.
I just say this is Dijkstra.
We'll talk about it
in lecture on Tuesday.
Very good.
AUDIENCE: Like, have
an adjacency list
and, I think using what he said.
Just sort it by cost--
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
see how this would work.
We have A, and we're
pulling A out of the list.
And we see its neighbors
are C and B. Right?
The distance to C is 2.
The distance to B is 4.
So we start with
A. Does this mean
that I'm going to
put in B before C?
I'm going to put
in C and then B?
AUDIENCE: No, it
doesn't really matter
because at the end you
just sort the part.
I guess you could
add in the costs.
Like associate the
costs of B with 4
and C with 2 within
your adjacency list?
PROFESSOR: So, that's how we
would keep track of costs,
right?
One way.
AUDIENCE: --for the
queue would be A
and then the value would be like
a [INAUDIBLE] B and its cost,
and the [INAUDIBLE]
C and its cost.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying that
what I would have in this list
is B with a cost of 4?
And C with a cost of 2?
Presumably, the other
way around, right?
C goes first?
Like This?
And then I take out C, I explore
the neighbors so and so forth?
The moment I did this I
already lost the battle.
Because, see this path
A, C, B, length 3?
If I put both of
them in the queue,
then the parent pointers
are going to look like this.
So, I already have a
bad path from B to A.
AUDIENCE: OK, well don't
add that node then.
PROFESSOR: OK, then
how do we do it?
AUDIENCE: I guess you
can talk to each of them
and see which one's
lower and then, only
add that one if it's the lowest.
So it's more like
depth search then--
PROFESSOR: Well, you two
need to talk together
because you're getting
to Dijkstra, too.
You're both going to
rediscover Dijkstra.
So that's great, but I'm
looking for something simple.
This is too complicated.
If you're going to
do Dijkstra now, then
what are going to do
on lecture on Tuesday?
AUDIENCE: More
Dijkstra problems?
PROFESSOR: Well, I think Shreeny
wants to talk about Dijkstra,
so let's not get there.
AUDIENCE: How do you do
this without doing Dijkstra?
PROFESSOR: Good.
That's exactly what
I want to know.
[LAUGHTER]
So, let me give
you another hint.
The first hint was that I
want to go through this edge
faster than I would
go through this edge.
The other hint is that we're
allowed to change the graph.
AUDIENCE: Is this what we
talked about in lecture,
or are we thinking
of something else?
PROFESSOR: He might
have talked about that
at the end of lecture.
AUDIENCE: Were you
putting the current weight
for each node
inside the circles?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: You could
add it and then
if you could find
a better path to B?
With rows relative
to A, then you
could just delete that path?
And B to 4?
So at the beginning you
add them all, but then--
PROFESSOR: You're risking to
have exponential running time.
AUDIENCE: (LAUGHS)
PROFESSOR: Those are
all valid optimizations
under some constraints.
Like, this one's good if you
don't have too much memory,
but the time goes up.
I want my graph to have
edges with no costs,
because if I have costs,
this is not going to work.
BFS is not going to work.
We can't tweak it.
If you could tweak it then that
would be another Turing Award.
AUDIENCE: So,
create dummy nodes?
PROFESSOR: Create dummy nodes.
How do I do that?
AUDIENCE:Put a band of
node in between A and C?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Why am I doing this?
So now I have two edges
and they have costs.
AUDIENCE: One.
Then you put three nodes
in between A and B.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And now here I have
four edges, right?
1, 1, 1, 1.
There was a 4 here before and
there was a 2 here before.
Do you guys see
what's happening?
So, instead of one edge
of cost C, I have C edges.
So, now BFS is going to take C
steps to go through that edge.
And all the edges now
have the same cost.
This looks like a problem
that BFS can solve.
We know it can solve.
We proved that it can solve it.
Well, CLRS did.
We take their word
for granted, sort of.
This works right?
Is everyone happy with it?
Does it make sense?
AUDIENCE: So basically,
we get through C
before you'll get to
B on the other path.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
This is the path of
length 3, so this node
is going to get in
the queue first.
Then this node.
Then these two nodes.
And they're going to
get in the queue from C.
Let's see what happened here.
This is really
important because this
is what you're going to
be doing in real life.
Chances of having to
build a new algorithm?
Kind of slim.
Why don't you want to do that?
Say you take Dijkstra and
you tweak it a little bit.
If you did that, you have
to go through the analysis
and prove the
running time again,
prove the correctness again.
Time-consuming, error-prone,
it's really hard.
However, what happened
here is that we
have some problem
that we want to solve.
Say we have the raw
input for that problem
that we're trying to solve.
That is this graph
that I draw the board.
And we apply some
transform and we
get an input that's
suitable for an algorithm
that we already know.
I'm going to take
a shortcut here.
We apply the transform, right?
We took this graph and
we built a new graph in.
And this is hopefully easy.
Right?
Take an edge and split it up.
Put in fake nodes.
This is easy.
We know how to code that.
And now we have this algorithm
that you already know,
and we're treating
it like a black box.
We know it's correct.
We know it's running time.
We're not questioning them.
We're taking them straight
from the textbook.
They have to be right.
By the way, what's the
running time of BFS?
AUDIENCE: V plus E?
PROFESSOR: Very good.
Then BFS is going to
give us a path, right?
And the path is going
to look like this.
It's going to be
A, fake node, C, D,
fake node, E. If you're giving
this back to the guy who
gave you the problem,
they're going to be like,
what are these fake nodes?
I don't know
anything about them.
This doesn't make sense.
You need to take this
raw output and you
need to transform it again.
Based on what you did
this transformation,
you have to read out the output.
You have to interpret it.
So, this is either
interpret or readout.
And then you get a
nice output that's
the output to your
original problem.
This process here is
the most likely way
in which you'll use
your 6006 knowledge.
And this is replaced by any
algorithm that we taught.
This is replaced by
any real life problem
that you'll encounter.
There's one missing step here.
We know the running
time for this.
Let's find out the running
time for the whole thing.
In order to do that,
we have to figure out
given this original graph.
Let's say that now,
in the original graph,
we have V prime vertices,
E prime edges, and W
prime weights.
We have to convert
this into V plus E.
We have to see when we make this
transform, how many vertices
do we get?
How many edges do we get in
terms of the original graph
so that we can compute
the running time?
In the original graph, V
prime vertices, E prime edges,
W prime weights.
In this new graph, how many
edges do I have, at most?
AUDIENCE: Something times E?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Perfect.
Each edge has cost
at most W. That
means we're going to split
it up into most W edges.
How many vertices
are we going to have?
AUDIENCE: W prime?
PROFESSOR: W prime, E prime.
AUDIENCE: Plus V prime?
PROFESSOR: Plus V prime.
Don't forget about
the original ones.
They're still there.
So, total running time for
BFS on this new graph is?
AUDIENCE: --E prime.
PROFESSOR: Put it the other way
around, plus W prime, E prime.
This is the running
time that we have.
Now, does anyone remember
Dijkstra's running time
and Bellam-Ford's running time?
So what is the running
time for Dijkstra?
AUDIENCE: V log V plus E?
PROFESSOR: Almost.
AUDIENCE: V log V?
PROFESSOR: Oh, wait.
I think you're right.
V log V plus--
AUDIENCE: E?
PROFESSOR: I already
named this from CRS?
Or is this what we got?
Entry is a fancy key to
give this running time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You can get this, but
you need the really fancy data
structure for it.
In real life, the running
time looks more like E log V.
And how about Bellam-Ford?
So let's take this
running time for Dijkstra
because this is
what you're going
to implement in real life.
And we can argue about that
after next lecture for now.
Take my word for it.
And let's compare it
to what we got here.
V is smaller than E
in most same cases.
Let's say that this is
actually W prime, E prime.
If you compare this
with this, you'll
see that, if W is smaller than
log V, well, smaller equal,
then this algorithm is
not worse than Dijkstra.
It's on par with Dijkstra.
For graphs with small costs,
we discovered an algorithm
that solves shortest paths.
You walked into this
recitation knowing no algorithm
to solve shortest path.
Now we have an algorithm.
Already in a much
better position.
Right?
And we didn't
invent anything new.
We don't have to
prove correctness.
All we did was one of
these transformations.
How's everyone feeling?
Those things makes sense?
Everyone happy?
Let's talk about another problem
that also uses this structure.
Suppose we have the
same graph that we
had before, or actually, any
graph with V vertices, E edges.
Now we know how to
compute shortest paths.
So we can assume
these as black boxes.
We're going to use
these as they are.
We have a graph with V
vertices and E edges.
Let me copy the
costs really quickly.
Suppose this is
the highway system,
right, like in Google Maps.
And we have two brothers.
They start off from
a place and they
have to end up in another place.
They're going to drive together.
They want this to
be sort of fair.
Every time they go
between two cities
they're going to switch
seats so that none of them
drives too much.
So say the brothers
are Tim and Jim.
The names are wrong.
This is actually a problem
from last year's quiz.
So, by the way, real problem.
You can pay attention now.
These are two brothers.
They're going to alternate.
Right?
One of them is going to
drive across one road,
then the other one, then the
first one, then the second one.
So on and so forth.
Now, two Tim has a much better
sense of direction than Jim.
That's just how things are.
And if you ever
driven long distances,
the hardest thing to do
is to get from the city
to the highway.
Like, if you have to drive
from here to New York.
Hardest thing to do?
Get out of Boston
and onto the highway.
Then, at the end, the
hardest thing to do?
Get from the highway
into where you
want to go through
New York traffic.
Everything else?
Piece of cake.
We want Tim to handle
both of these situations.
The driving path must start
with Tim and must end with Tim.
Otherwise, God knows,
they're going to crash.
First off let's convert
this into graph terms.
And then let's solve it.
AUDIENCE: You might convert
what's already in the graph.
PROFESSOR: I have
this constraint
that they're going to switch
seats and that Tim has to start
and Tim has to end.
How do I phrase
this in mathy terms?
In graph terms?
AUDIENCE: We're starting
it where and ending where?
PROFESSOR: We're given
where in the graph.
We're starting at S, ending at
T. Some points in the graph.
AUDIENCE: And people have to
drive with it an entire edge?
PROFESSOR: Ya.
AUDIENCE: So basically,
Jim has to-- whoever
the good driver has to--
to drive on the edge that's
adjacent to E and S.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
OK.
AUDIENCE: You physically need,
like an odd number of edges.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So I want the shortest path
with an odd number of edges.
Why odd number of edges?
If we look at the edges, Tim's
going to take the first one.
Then Jim, then Tim, then
Jim, then Tim, then Jim.
No matter how many I have
here, it has to end with Tim.
So, I'm going to have an
odd number of letters here,
therefore, odd number of edges.
Right?
So I want the shortest path
that has an odd number of edges.
And as the hint we're going
to use that trick over there.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: But, the shortest
path isn't necessarily
like the fairest, right?
Like, in terms of
distributing driving?
PROFESSOR: One of them is
going to drive one more road,
such is life.
Sorry, one more edge segment.
Tim's going to
drive three times,
Jim is going to drive two times.
AUDIENCE: Right, but like,
in terms of the weights?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
We don't care about that.
Jim doesn't know where
he's going anyways.
AUDIENCE: Just a minimum, we
have to have like three paths,
right?
We don't just want Tim
to get out to the highway
and be like, oh look our
journey's not that far--
PROFESSOR: So I went to the
path with the smallest cost.
So, smallest total weight.
AUDIENCE: In theory it
could be length, too.
Right?
PROFESSOR: Well, if
it's length, too,
then it's not going to be good
because they're going to crash.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
They have to switch every time.
PROFESSOR: Tim can't drive
for two consecutive edges.
AUDIENCE: You could use
breadth-first search
and, once you get
to the end point,
or made all paths that
are [INAUDIBLE] and then,
of those paths,
go through to see
which one's the lowest cost?
PROFESSOR: You're
thinking enumerate
all paths of even length?
Just to make sure I got it.
So this is cool
because it let's me
show something else that's cool.
So, enumerate all
paths of even length.
Something else I
heard, enumerate
all the shortest paths.
For both of these, let's
look at this graph.
S, T, all the paths
have length 1.
How many ways are there
to get from S to T?
AUDIENCE: Two to three.
PROFESSOR: Two to three.
Two ways to go
across this diamond.
Two ways to go across this one.
Right?
2 times 2 times 2?
8.
If I add another
diamond, how many paths?
One more?
So the number of even paths, or
the number of shortest paths,
the number of whatever paths I
can think about is, order of?
Come on, guys.
Math.
Rrrr!
Go!
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: 2 to a
number of diamonds?
PROFESSOR: Which is?
Roughly to the vertices.
Exponential in the
number of vertices.
Not very good, not very good.
We can't do this.
So, it's better that we
talked about it here,
then that you try
to do it on the quiz
and you have to discover
this on your own, right?
Good comment.
AUDIENCE: Didn't understand
what you meant by that lecture.
Now it makes sense.
PROFESSOR: That's
completely different.
AUDIENCE: That wasn't the
thing he was talking about?
PROFESSOR: That's different.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: That's where
relaxation can go wrong.
So if you show that if you relax
the edges in a random order,
you can have an exponential
number of steps.
This shows that there are an
exponential number of paths
for any graph, no matter
how good your algorithm is.
So we're not going to be
able to enumerate them.
Let's try something else.
AUDIENCE: You have
another suggestion?
Just look at all the--
PROFESSOR: So,
you're doing this.
You're looking here.
Everyone's looking here.
How about this?
AUDIENCE: We should do that?
PROFESSOR: Ther's that, right?
There's a transform.
You need to transform
your graph in some way,
then run the algorithm.
And then reading off the
outputs should be easy.
I claim that the hard step
is the transform step, not
the read off step.
Let me give you one
more piece of intuition.
We're going to keep
track of states, somehow.
Remember Rubik's cube?
We had one vertex
for each state.
A state representing the
configuration of the cube.
Here, suppose I'm looking
at the path from S
to D. The problem
that I have with this
is that, if I have an algorithm
that tells me the shortest
path from S to D is something,
I don't know if it's even
or if it's odd.
It's not keeping track of that.
It's missing some state.
The state that it's
missing is whether the path
that I used to get here
is even or odd length.
I should do something
to the graph
to keep track of this state.
AUDIENCE: Can you BFS it once?
To plan-- You BFS once.
Then you that B and
C are all like 108,
and then you know
that E and D are 208?
PROFESSOR: B 208 if
I take this path.
It might be 108, might be 208.
But, this is good.
This is what you'll
do on a quiz, right?
You come up with
an idea and then
you're going to think
about it for a bit.
If you get stuck, try
to convince yourself
that it's wrong.
If things get too hard, discard
and look somewhere else.
This is thought process, right?
You think of something,
backtrack, backtrack,
backtrack, and eventually you
get to the right solution.
Let's go over the
solution for this one,
and then I'll give you a hard
one that is sort of like this.
Then I'll want the solution
from you for that one.
I'm going to draw this
graph in a bigger version,
so I'll have to erase this.
So this is a cool concept.
You will be able to do
a lot of things with it.
AUDIENCE: Is this one
solvable by Dijkstra?
PROFESSOR: Ya.
AUDIENCE: Just curious.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we'll
run Dijkstra on it
after we transform it.
These are big nodes!
Why am I doing it this way?
AUDIENCE: (LAUGHS) Is that
like, Seattle, Portland, San
Francisco?
PROFESSOR: It's because I'm
going to need room for copies.
I'm going to make a copy of each
node to keep track of state.
AUDIENCE: Gosh.
PROFESSOR: So,
instead of one node
I'll have two nodes
for each node.
And I have two
nodes because this
is what lets me keep track of
state, odd path or even path.
Let me erase the edges
because that's not
how it's going to
work, actually.
Instead of having a node A, I'm
going to have a node A even.
And I'm going to
have a copy, A odd.
E even, I'm going to
have to copy, V odd.
C even, copies to C odd.
D even, make a copy to D odd.
Wait, this is E, sorry.
Sorry, my bad.
[QUIET TALKING]
Suppose I got to A using
an even length path.
If I take the edge
from A to B, I
will get to B using an even
length path, or an odd length
path?
AUDIENCE: Odd.
PROFESSOR: So, if I get to A
using an even length path, then
from there I'll get to B
using an odd length path.
Sorry, four.
Using this exact road.
AUDIENCE: A really
messed-up graph.
PROFESSOR: That's a
nice way to name it.
[WOMAN LAUGHING]
I've heard worse.
If I get to A using an
odd number of edges,
how many edges will I
have and I get to B?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this edge
became these edges here.
Now let's do the
edge between B and E.
I get to be using an
even number of edges.
I take B. Do I get to
the even or to the odd?
AUDIENCE: Odd.
PROFESSOR: I get to
B using an odd path.
What are the lengths
of these paths?
AUDIENCE: 5.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
God, this is starting to
look ugly, you're right.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's do A, C and stop there.
A even is connected to?
AUDIENCE: Odd.
PROFESSOR: C odd, by
a path the length.
And A odd is connected to
C even by a path of length.
Is this starting to make sense?
So all the edges are
going to look like this.
AUDIENCE: So are those like
two independent graphs?
PROFESSOR: Well, I have
edges connecting them.
But, I like your question.
The reason this is
ugly is because I'm
looking at a 2D
projection of a 3D graph.
If I had a holographic display,
which would be a lot nicer,
then I would do something
along these lines.
Two pieces of paper.
I would draw the original graph,
and call it the even graph.
Put it here.
I would draw the graph
again, call it the odd graph,
and put it here.
So this is my 2D graph.
This is my map,
the original map.
And this is state.
The third dimension is state.
When I'm at a node, and I
used an even number of edges
to get here, I'm going
to go take one edge
and go to another node using
an odd number of edges.
So all the edges are
going to go from here
to here, and from here to here.
Does it makes more sense now?
So the reason that looks
ugly is because you're
seeing the graph like this.
If you could see like this,
and maybe play with it
a little bit, it
would make more sense.
It wouldn't look as ugly.
There are two graphs, the
even graph and the odd graph.
And the edges between them
represent you doing something.
When you take the highway, you
transition from an even state
to an odd state, and from an
odd state to an even state.
So that's why the edges
are the way they are.
Now let me see if
you guys get it.
What node do I start from?
What node do I
want to end up in?
AUDIENCE: A, and
you're ending up at B?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Oh, there's two--
PROFESSOR: I heard
three answers.
One of them is correct.
Do you want to vote or do you
guys want to figure it out?
Talk it out?
Fight?
AUDIENCE: A even, E odd.
PROFESSOR: We start from A
even and we end up at E odd.
Why do I started at A even?
AUDIENCE: We've seen
exactly zero cities
when we started out.
PROFESSOR: Yep, so
the original path
has length the 0, which
happens to be even.
And we want to end up
with an odd length path.
So if we go from here
to here-- see how
because we have two nodes
out of each original node,
the path is going to alternate
between even and odd.
And is going to keep
track of the state
that they didn't
have before, and it's
going to just do
the right thing.
It's magic!
It works!
Let's see what is the
running this new algorithm.
Say my original
graph had V and E.
How many new vertices do I have?
AUDIENCE: Two kinds.
PROFESSOR: How many edges?
AUDIENCE: Twice?
PROFESSOR: Each edge is
copied exactly twice.
Which algorithm
am I going to use?
All my weights are
positive because they're
the time it takes
to drive somewhere,
the distance or something.
So which algorithm do I use?
AUDIENCE: Breadth-first search?
PROFESSOR: We can't use
breadth-first search
because you have weight.
So breadth-first search is not
going to find the right answer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, you
want to use this thing.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Well,
so we don't have
to worry about that because
now we put the shortest path
algorithm in the black
box and we have them.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so we
can use them now.
PROFESSOR: We use
these black boxes.
But what we need to know is
when to use this black box
and when is this black box.
Which boxes faster, by the way?
Please, please give
me the right answer.
AUDIENCE: Dijkstra?
PROFESSOR: All right!
Dijkstra is faster.
[LAUGHTER]
So whenever we can use
Dijkstra we will use Dijkstra.
When can't we use Dijkstra?
AUDIENCE: When it's
negative, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Negative--
AUDIENCE: Weights.
PROFESSOR: Negative weights.
If I have weights
greater or equal to 0,
I'm happy I can use Dijkstra.
If I have weights that are
smaller than 0, well, whatever.
It's going to be slower,
but I can still solve it.
AUDIENCE: It's like
arbitrary negative weights.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Arbitrary negative weights.
So all the edges here are
positive, so I'm going to use--
AUDIENCE: Dijkstra.
PROFESSOR: Dijkstra!
Very good.
So the running time
will be, order of--
AUDIENCE: V log V?
PROFESSOR: V log V plus E.
If you're a theory person,
if you're in real
life it's E log V.
This is exactly the running
time for the original graph.
The transformation only
increased the graph size
by a constant factor.
So, same running time.
Pretty good, right?
OK, let's do one more problem.
Let's do the hard problem now.
Are you guys getting ready
for the hard problem?
AUDIENCE: If we hadn't
seen this probably
wouldn't have thought of it.
I wouldn't even
think about this.
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
why we taught you this.
So I wanted to do two things.
I wanted to show you that
trick, which is a cool trick,
keep track of state
by multiplying
the vertices that you have.
And I wanted to go through
some wrong solutions
and figure out why
they're wrong so you
can develop an intuition.
Because, when you're going
to get a new problem,
you're going to
think of something.
Unless you're really
good, unless you
are destined to win a
Turing Award of some sort,
the first solution
will probably be wrong.
Even if you're destined
to win a Turing Award,
the first thing that comes to
mind will probably be wrong.
I'm willing to bet Dijkstra
didn't think of Dijkstra
off the top of his head when
he heard about the problem.
What you want to do
is get an intuition.
So you think of a solution and
it starts getting complicated,
or things start
looking wrong, you
want to back out and
think of something else.
The more things we can consider,
higher chances that you're
going to stumble upon
the correct solution.
So that's why we are building
an intuition for bad solutions.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not just saying,
hey, give me a solution
and now I'll tell
you it's wrong.
It's not just to embarrass
you or something.
There's that intuition
building step.
That's really important.
There's this network that
we keep talking about.
There's this highway
network, except this time
it's a bit more complicated.
So for each edge
I have two things.
I have a fuel cost,
which is constant.
A fuel cost is a function
of the length of the road.
But now, I have these realistic
highways where I have traffic.
If you try to go from
Boston to New York, 2 AM?
Three hours.
Rush hour?
Six hours.
So we have to keep track
of this in some way.
Well we're going to split
up the day into minutes.
Say you have 10
minutes in a day.
Can anyone tell me what
M is, really quickly?
Not a number, a
formula, something.
AUDIENCE: What's 3,600 times 24?
And that's seconds.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So this is how many
minutes in a day.
This is how many minutes
we have in a day, right?
For each edge, we're going
to have a function that's
the time cost of the edge.
So it's the time cost of this
edge, and it's going to say,
if I start at a
certain time, it's
going to take this many
minutes to go across the edge.
For each highway I
know how much time
it's going to take to go
across it, given when I start.
And I know much fuel
I'm going to consume.
By the way, edges are
directed now, just
to make our life easy.
This graph is going
to be like this.
Let's see if I can
get this right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the
real reason I'm
having this is the time
to go across the highway
might be different,
depending which way you go.
AUDIENCE:Oh--
PROFESSOR: Getting into
Boston in the morning
versus getting into
Boston in the evening.
Which one's easier?
Sorry, versus getting out
of Boston in the morning.
Intuitively, I'd say
it's probably harder
to get in in the morning because
people are going to work.
And it's easier to get out.
But ya, I don't know either.
AUDIENCE: The 95 one's a hurdle.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR:We have an answer.
Our edges are going
to be oriented.
I want to find an itinerary
that satisfies two constraints.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ya, that's
not good, right?
New York and New York.
[WOMAN LAUGHING]
So I want to see how fast I
can get to my destination.
That's my top priority.
If I get to New York at 5:00 PM,
I want to get there at 5:00 PM.
I don't want to get there
at 5:01, for example.
But if I have three ways
to get there at 5:00 PM,
I want to choose the way
that's the most eco-friendly.
So, the least amount of fuel.
So out of all possible
ways, the fastest way?
Out of all possible
fastest ways,
the way that consumes
the least fuel?
Go.
You have two minutes.
Maybe five.
AUDIENCE: And we have
the same costs for the--
PROFESSOR: Each edge always
has the same fuel cost.
But, depending on when
you start, going across it
is going to take a
different time, too.
AUDIENCE: And we don't
know what those times are?
PROFESSOR: They're going to
be different for each edge.
AUDIENCE: One guess,
take Dijkstra.
Find the shortest
path length and we
look for all path lengths
that are that length.
I don't know.
PROFESSOR: So we have the issue
that-- I might still have it.
Oh no, never mind.
Sorry, I erased it so it's
not on your mind anymore.
We have those
diamonds that show you
that there might be an
exponential number of paths
with the same length,
or the same distance.
AUDIENCE: And it
doesn't help that we
know we should cut off the--
PROFESSOR: Nope.
So we need to do the
process that I just erased.
Transform the graph in.
The thing is, now you're
missing state, right?
This misses state.
This tells you
how many edges you
have to get from
source to destination.
But we're not keeping track of
some state that these vital.
Transform the graph to
keep track of state,
run, say Dijkstra, and
then interpret the output.
What state do we need?
Let's think of that.
AUDIENCE: Fuel cost, I think.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The two costs
is the same for each edge.
It's just the time is different.
To be in traffic.
AUDIENCE: But once we have
found the fastest spot
that we wanted to see cut
into our fuel cost range
and which one do
we want to take.
Thinking about the priority,
our priority is time.
So we want to save fuels
as a state, to check it?
PROFESSOR: The problem
is I don't even
know if fuel costs are integers.
I can't keep fuel as a state.
How many copies would I have?
For each vertex how
many copies would
I have if fuel is a state?
Who knows?
So let's try something else.
But, you're on the right track.
Let's take a variable
and make it state.
AUDIENCE: So for every
vertex can you keep
track of what's the shortest
time it took to get there?
PROFESSOR: What's the shortest
How would you keep
track of that?
Would you make
that state, or how
would you keep track of that?
I'm not disagreeing.
I'm trying to understand your--
AUDIENCE: So for example,
let's say if you have B, right?
Let's say it takes like
one hour to go from A to B.
PROFESSOR: It depends when
you start, by the way.
How much time it takes
depends on when you start.
If you start at 8:00
AM, it might be an hour.
If you start at 9:00 AM
it might be two hours.
AUDIENCE: Do you need to have
a finite number of states?
PROFESSOR: It's nice
if it's not infinite,
but it doesn't have to be
constant, like we had before.
It can be more than
constant, for sure.
So what are you thinking?
AUDIENCE: I want to
use time as a state.
PROFESSOR: I like that idea.
Let's try to do it.
We're going to use
time as a state.
How many vertices am I going
to have for each vertex?
So for each original
vertex, how many vertices
am I going to have
in my new graph?
AUDIENCE: Three or
four [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: The sum of all times?
PROFESSOR: So if I say, hey,
I'm at this vertex at this time,
then I'm going to
have M vertices
for each original vertex, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: I promise that the
resolution of time is minutes.
I promise that this
thing gives you
an integer number of minutes.
AUDIENCE: Can it be
put into days, though?
PROFESSOR: Suppose we can get
from source to destination
in one day.
So let's see how it
builds this graph first,
and then we can figure out
the rest of the things.
So for each node I'm going
to make M copies of it.
Suppose in my original
graph I had a node.
I'm going to have M
copies of that node.
And each copy has
the original vertex,
and the time when I'm there.
Right?
There are V of these.
And there are M of these.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It
totally makes sense.
It's a great idea.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you had it!
Great idea.
So far so good.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Now they
need to be connected
to the appropriate next one.
PROFESSOR: Let's
hear how we do that.
Suppose we have an
edge from U to V.
How are going to connect this?
How are we going
to transform this?
How many edges are going
to make from that edge?
AUDIENCE: Do you have to do
it from every start time?
I guess.
So you'd write M edges.
PROFESSOR: M edges.
From U and a start
time to V and what?
AUDIENCE:T plus T C of T.
PROFESSOR: T plus T C of
going through that edge.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: T C are going
from U to V at the stop.
Ya, like this.
So you start from a time.
So the edge points from
the time that you start up
until the time when
you'd be able to finish.
So, up until the time where
you'd be off the highway
and die in the next city.
And we need one
more type of edges.
There's one more tiny trick.
If I'm somewhere in
Massachusetts, and I know that
it's really bad now.
I prefer to wait out for a
few minutes, go to a bar,
and then come and drive-- OK not
to a bar-- go to a food place,
then drive later.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: --vertical
edges that--
PROFESSOR: --represent waiting.
AUDIENCE: You have to add
one minute between them.
PROFESSOR: How do I do that?
AUDIENCE: From U to
U with a cost of 1.
PROFESSOR: So from
U to U at 20 plus 1.
I like this better.
What's the fuel cost of this?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: So here this
edge had fuel cost at C,
Then the new edge
is going have fuel
cost for the ones on the top.
AUDIENCE: Is it
proportional to minutes?
Speed?
PROFESSOR: It's the same.
F C stays the same, no matter
when we go through the highway
if C is a function of
the distance of the road.
This edge becomes M
edges with the same cost.
And then I have to have
vertical waiting edges.
If we had the
holographic display
that I talked about earlier
you'd have M sheets of paper
this time.
You start at time
0 at your source
and then your edges go represent
the moves that you can make.
So, you could start
in Boston at 8:00 AM.
And you could take
I-90 and end up
in-- I don't know Massachusetts
city names-- Albuquerque
at 9:00 AM?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Amherst.
PROFESSOR: Amherst, OK.
So you started in
Boston 8:00 AM,
you end up at Amherst
at 9, 10:00 AM.
Right?
So this is one edge.
The edges represent
the moves that you
could make in this graph.
Does this makes?
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
the two last lines there.
I don't really get what we
were doing there [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's see what
we're trying to do here.
We're saying that, if I'm a node
U, and I'm starting at time T.
AUDIENCE: Ya, so that's
like one piece of paper.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
I'm going to go on
the road, right?
the road from U to V.
So where am I going to arrive?
AUDIENCE: There at V
at some time plus that.
PROFESSOR: Now we have
to figure out what time
we're going to arrive at.
The time that we arrive
at is the original time,
plus whatever time I'm
going to spend on the road.
What's the time I
spend on the road?
It's not constant because
I have that timetable that
includes traffic.
So this is what this tells me.
This is what this big,
ugly formula is all about.
It says the timetable
for this edge assuming
you start at time T.
That's all there is.
Nothing else.
AUDIENCE: What's the
second line, then?
PROFESSOR: So the
second line is waiting.
So if I don't have this
then I'm constrained
in that I have to
drive all the time.
I go from here to
Amherst, then I
have to go from Amherst to
somewhere else, and keep going,
keep going, keep going.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this is
where I wait for a minute.
If I wait for a minute,
I don't consume any fuel
and I go from time
T to time T plus 1.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Does this make sense?
Do we want to analyze the
running time for this really
quickly?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: How many edges?
AUDIENCE: E times M?
PROFESSOR: OK, let's do vertices
because vertices is quick.
AUDIENCE: V times M?
PROFESSOR: So, edges is,
you're saying, V times M?
Almost.
AUDIENCE: Pause there.
PROFESSOR: So there's
a pause, right?
How many pause edges do I have?
AUDIENCE: V-- M.
PROFESSOR: This is
how many vertices?
This is how many edges?
Plug this into which algorithm,
Dijkstra or Bellam-Ford?
AUDIENCE: Dijkstra.
PROFESSOR: Done!
Yay, we solved the hard problem.
AUDIENCE: How do you ensure
that the time's right?
Do you have to go through
and see if there's a path?
PROFESSOR: How do we
read the solution?
That's good.
That's a good question.
I like that.
So, we're going to have M
vertices of the destination.
Alright?
Let's see how they're
going to look like.
First off, if you
start at 8:00 AM,
maybe you're not going to make
it to New York at 8:01 AM.
The vertex that says
New York at 8:01 AM
is probably going to have
a cost of plus infinity.
First off the really
early times are
going to have a cost
of plus infinity.
Not going to happen.
Then, at some point, the cost
is going to become finite.
That's the fastest way you can
get from Boston to New York.
using the least amount of fuel.
So the cost that you have there
is the answer to our problem.
AUDIENCE: So basically,
when you get there you
have to enter it through all M.
PROFESSOR: All M vertices that
correspond to the destination.
The costs are going
to look like this.
They're going to be infinity,
infinity, infinity all the way
up, until some
point in here you're
going to have your final answer.
The cost to get
there the fastest--
see, you can get
there at 3:00 PM.
This is how much fuel you have
to spend to get there at 3;00
PM.
But, if you're willing
to wait until 3:01 PM,
you're going to have the fastest
cost you can have for that.
If you're willing
to wait until 3:02,
you're going to have the
answer for that, too.
So here you're going to get
the whole trade-off curve of,
if you're willing to
wait for a few minutes,
or if you're willing to
wait for an extra hour, how
much fuel you can save.
So, I think that's cool
about your questions.
You had a question, too.
AUDIENCE: Why did
we have V times M
in the E prime expression?
PROFESSOR: First off, we
have E times M, right?
We're good with these.
These are the waiting edges.
AUDIENCE: So we are
waiting after every minute?
PROFESSOR: The waiting
edges are vertex time
to vertex time plus 1.
How many vertices?
V. How many times?
AUDIENCE: M.
PROFESSOR: So it's V times
M. Because at each minute,
you can be at a
certain city and decide
to wait one more minute
to stay the same city.
OK Does this make sense?
Thank you guys!
I'm really happy we
solved the hard problem!
That's good.